我們竟然有35種癌症
都可能跟黴菌有關
因為台灣就是很潮濕嘛
現在又有颱風啊水災啊
在這個環境生活的人
其實身上的黴菌毒素的含量
也是特別高的
很常見的症狀
可不可以給我們幾個
吃硫化物會變得很奇怪的反應的人
譬如說大蒜洋蔥
甚至是十字花科的食物
這些我們聽起來覺得超健康
很棒的食物
就是你某一個地方
就是一定有黴菌
鼻過敏
不管是過敏性鼻炎還是鼻竇炎
認知功能障礙或是失智症腦霧
它會穿過BBB(血腦屏障)
它的功能就是要預防
任何危險的東西跑到腦裡面
但是黴菌毒素竟然
它可以長驅直入
嗨大家好我是雯心醫師
你知道嗎
很多人啊這種健康上的困擾
譬如說疲勞
整天不知道在累什麼
然後一直在過敏
慢性發炎
還有門診最常見的就是
反覆減肥
但是
有一個隱藏的重大原因
可能是你到現在都還不知道的
黴菌毒素
哇講到這個這麼專業的一個話題
我請到了我的好朋友
超全能診所的王偉全醫師
來跟我們分享
讓我們歡迎他
謝謝謝謝雯心
非常高興
我們在台灣就是一個潮濕
充滿黴菌的環境
我不覺得
它會帶來給我一個什麼很重大的影響
一直到呢去上課的時候
這個《Cell》期刊裡面它說
我們竟然有35種癌症
都可能跟黴菌有關
而且我們在這些癌症病人身上
竟然看到黴菌的DNA是卡在裡面的
那我就覺得奇怪了
可是我沒有在吃什麼發霉的食物啊
就是看到發霉我一定丟掉啊
是
那它們是怎麼進到我身體來影響我的啊
我們個案裡面就有人
他吃那個豆干
他吃完之後才發現
欸它下面剩下的東西好像有發霉
那其實我們空氣中
也都是充滿黴菌的孢子
但是黴菌毒素本身
它其實是沒有味道的
欸所以意思是說
我就算沒有看到它
甚至是我也不一定聞得到
它還是有可能透過飲食
或者是吸入這個環境中的黴菌
然後製造黴菌毒素
或是黴菌孢子本身進入到身體裡面來
等一下
我覺得我有一個很科普的問題
黴菌
黴菌孢子
黴菌毒素
它們是不一樣的東西
不一樣的東西
黴菌毒素它沒有生命
黴菌毒素是黴菌孢子的代謝產物
它在有壓力的情況之下
才會分泌出來的東西
而且這個東西它是脂溶性的
所以它會囤積在你的身體的
任何的脂肪組織裡面
所以它是很難排出去的
然後脂溶性還有一個更麻煩的地方
它會攻擊粒線體
會深入細胞裡面
然後造成慢性的疲勞啊
然後慢性的發炎
然後產生氧化壓力
然後你說黴菌要在有壓力的環境下面
會產生毒素
它們是在自然界存活的一個方式嗎
其實是有研究發現
自然環境中的黴菌
其實它不見得會製造黴菌毒素
它是當有壓力
譬如說有其他的生物
想要來侵略它的地盤
它才會想要分泌這些黴菌毒素
那它進到我們的現代人的環境
比如說這些鋼筋水泥
或者是浴室廚房
或者是冷氣空調
或是我們自己的身體
免疫系統會攻擊它們
第二個是現代人的飲食環境
對飲食的東西
你各種的零食各種的加工食品
這些環境對它來講
可能是有壓力的
很險惡的
很險惡的環境是對它不友善的環境
所以它就開始大量的製造黴菌毒素
那我們先來想想看
我們平常的居家有沒有什麼隱形的地方
有可能是它們隱藏的點
我們需要去注意的
因為台灣就是很潮濕嘛
然後你看現在又有颱風啊
然後水災啊什麼一大堆的
在這個環境
水損建築環境生活的人
其實身上的這個黴菌毒素的含量
也是特別高的
所以第一件事情還是要去找
當然就是有沒有漏水啊
有沒有壁癌啊
有沒有黴斑
有些人就是翻開他的那個沙發
或是翻開他的床墊
或是他的洗衣機
然後裡面才發現一堆黴菌
然後有些人是空調系統
還有一位個案是這個室內盆栽
室內盆栽其實那個土壤也是要去維護
要定期的去翻土
我現在已經在想我家裡
哪些地方還要清理一下
那食物呢
食物我們不一定看得到它發黴啊
有沒有哪些食物是
比較容易會有黴菌潛藏的
一般來講還是穀物類
像之前就有那個花生醬
發現裡面有黃麴毒素的部分
然後再來就是
咖啡豆
咖啡豆很可怕
因為我有專門在烘豆的朋友
他們自己就要挑出瑕疵豆
可是有很多他發現
它是被黴菌侵蝕的咖啡豆
那這個裡面就有可能有黴菌毒素
然後事實上也有一些研究發現
咖啡豆裡面有些可以分析出來有
赭麴毒素啊黃麴毒素啊
等等的這些毒素
然後再來就是
莓果類的特別有機會
印象中王醫師好像
本人也是個被黴菌影響的過來人
沒錯
自己的症狀跟當初怎麼發現
其實最早會接觸黴菌毒素
就是因為我是做增生療法
那我自己本身就是因為
很多很多的疼痛
加上有其他的伴隨的症狀
比如說我就是很嚴重的疲勞感
那另外就是
我從小到大其實會一直流鼻水
那一開始就是想說
欸會不會是過敏原
可是我驗了過敏原好像還好
所以就覺得
欸是不是事有蹊蹺
然後後來就是認識了很多很多的大師
然後跟他們聊之後他們就覺得
我的症狀應該是比較指向黴菌毒素
所以我才踏上了這個旅程
剛已經有提到一些
我覺得很多人應該有共鳴的症狀欸
如果說我們現在要整理成一些
顯而易見很常見的症狀
可不可以給我們幾個
我有整理出5大症狀
那前兩個就是我剛剛講的
鼻過敏
不管是過敏性鼻炎還是鼻竇炎
第二個就是慢性疲勞
因為它會影響粒線體
然後第三個就是
認知功能障礙或是失智症腦霧
因為它是脂溶性的
它會穿過BBB
就是血腦屏障
腦的這一層Barrier
其實它應該是要很強壯
它的功能就是要預防
任何危險的東西跑到腦裡面
但是黴菌毒素竟然
它可以長驅直入
然後甚至有研究發現
赭麴毒素它會到海馬迴
就是我們的記憶中樞
所以其實它是會
影響我們的記憶力專注力
再來就是慢性疼痛
就是怎麼會這麼痛
然後怎麼樣治療都效果不好
那就要考慮是不是有別的原因
造成慢性發炎
然後第五個比較特別的是震顫
你看過神經科的醫師
然後他跟你說有點像癲癇
肌張力不全帕金森氏症
可是又不典型
身體會抖的這些震顫的症狀
這個都有可能跟黴菌毒素有關
一個是有點像帕金森氏症這樣
但是另外一個是黴菌毒素的大師
叫Neil Nathan
他在他的書裡面有提到
一種很特別的震顫感
叫做Internal vibration
就是內在震顫
他說是從脊髓裡面出來的
哇那我覺得這些症狀真的就是
很nonspecific
但是
我覺得在減重個案上
我倒是也是有一個印象深刻的案例
他就是一直減不下來
然後他其實已經也算是吃的健康了
然後也都是有在運動
我想說
那不然我們就驗一下黴菌毒素好了
就還真的被我抓到
然後我就是先用了一些營養治療啊
然後跟改善粒線體的一些東西
包括點滴
然後他就
欸他的體重就開始鬆動了
但我覺得他也非常的
算是很認真
就是他一旦知道這件事情後
他就去大整理他的家裡
上課的時候
我就問Dr. Jill Crista這件事情
就是說確實
他臨床上也看到
很多人就是反覆減肥
減不下來這樣
我覺得可能跟我們剛剛講
毒素是脂溶性的
是有關係
因為我們的脂肪會想要把毒素包住
那我今天如果減了
可是黴菌毒素還在的話
那我們身體的防禦系統
當然自然而然的
又會想要把它包回去
有沒有一些也是比較特殊的就是
如果有這一個症狀
你也會相當程度的懷疑
其中一個就是很頻尿
就是有點類似膀胱過動症
當然這個我第一個還是會先請他去
泌尿科或是婦產科看
但是那邊如果遇到一些瓶頸的話
我真的會建議他驗黴菌毒素
但是為什麼啊
我覺得第一個很大的原因
可能跟念珠菌感染有關係
它會製造一個叫做膠黴毒素
各種的黴菌毒素
不管是哪一種
都會去影響我們的免疫系統
然後我們的免疫系統裡面
有一個叫做TH2的
它是跟過敏跟敏感性有關的東西
黴菌毒素它會把這個敏感性拉高
它會在膀胱壁裡面製造很多肥大細胞
肥大細胞最有名的就是
它會製造很多的組織胺
組織胺就會讓你的膀胱變得很敏感
一點點水進來
就很想要收縮就蠢蠢欲動
那還有一種
對傳統治療反應不佳
沒錯
或者是說明明吃什麼藥
要有什麼症狀改善的
但他竟然沒有
我甚至有病人吃類固醇
讓他減少過敏了
可是他吃了類固醇之後
反而過敏了更嚴重
天啊我現在腦中冒出好多
那如果譬如說
我們現在很常用更年期荷爾蒙治療
他用荷爾蒙反而反應不好的
是
也有沒有可能
有可能
有一種特別的黴菌毒素
叫做玉米赤黴烯酮
對然後另外還有一個叫思鎌孢菌素
這兩種毒素
都是專門會影響荷爾蒙的
看到這邊你應該已經知道
黴菌毒素不會只從食物裡面來喔
所以我們幫大家整理了一份
黴菌毒素來源與症狀的對照表
如果想要知道的話
就點擊右上方的連結領取喔
有沒有在您臨床上常常檢測到的
比較常見的一些黴菌毒素
有兩隻黴菌毒素
測起來的比率特別高
第一個就是膠黴毒素
膠黴毒素就是剛剛講的
念珠菌或是其他的一些黴菌
會製造的一個東西
再來因為它的化學結構裡面有
雙硫鍵就是有硫化物
吃硫化物會變得很奇怪的反應的人
就是譬如說大蒜
洋蔥
或者是甚至是十字花科的食物
這些我們聽起來覺得超健康
很棒的食物
所以如果有膠黴毒素的話
就是不管在鼻子呼吸道
還是泌尿生殖系統
還是腸胃道
就是你某一個地方
就是一定有黴菌
第二個叫做黴酚酸
它是代表你的外界
你現在所處的環境裡面有黴菌
這個黴酚酸
它是所有的黴菌毒素裡面
唯一一個水溶性的
水溶性的意思就是說
理論上你只要離開那個環境
你的身體是有辦法自然把它代謝掉的
可是卻驗出來很高
那就代表你現在的環境
也是somewhere
就是一定有黴菌
喔一個是外面的黴菌
一個是裡面的黴菌
一定要去找出來啦
好我覺得聽到這邊
鏡頭前面的你
是不是每個人都覺得
自己身上有黴菌毒素對不對
所以一般我們在飲食上面
有沒有一些重點可以讓我們去
鞏固我們身體的這些系統
當然第一個就是先戒糖
糖的話對大部分的黴菌來說
都是一個滋養的作用
再來就是多補充這個好油
像橄欖油
黑種草油
或是有些魚油
有一些比較好的
有殺菌效果的精油
也會對排除掉黴菌毒素有幫助
還有再來
膳食纖維
喔纖維
其實是很好的
還有益生菌的部分
主要有幾個益生菌特別有幫助
因為你既然給它好的纖維了
可以當做很好的一個益生元
比如說乳酸桿菌
還有我們有時候會針對這個過敏的族群
去使用這個布拉迪菌
還有一種叫做土壤益生菌
對於黴菌毒素的排除
其實是特別有幫助的
欸不錯體內環保
那體外呢
就是我們是不是在環境上面
要注意一些事情
不要讓黴菌繼續存活下去
比如說室內盆栽啊
然後你如果有一些漏水
黴菌黴斑的地方
壁癌的部分
這個當然第一個一定要先去處理掉
那萬一你真的找半天找不到怎麼辦
那最簡單的方法
其實就是使用空氣清淨機
還有除濕機
其實有研究發現
(濕度)50%以下的話
就可以抑制黴菌的生長
然後我自己以前犯了一個錯誤
是每次訂包裹的時候
嗯
然後我箱子就堆在那邊
對因為紙張它很容易吸水嘛
所以它容易爛掉
然後甚至有一些
國外有一些比較嚴格的黴菌毒素的專家
他們都覺得不要是那種很open的書架
可以關起來的書架會比較好
因為那些書也有驗出黃麴毒素過
oh my god
我家是開放式書櫃
看來要回去再大整理一下
那我相信應該還是有很多人覺得說
他吃也吃的很健康
然後家裡他也沒有發現可疑之處
但他還是覺得黴菌毒素在干擾他
所以在治療上面
王醫生就會有一些比較特別的步驟
來幫助這些人是不是
是
第一步還是要建議要做檢測
先確立診斷
每一個排毒的方式是完全不一樣的
我總歸有四個
叫做4D排毒療法
這個在我的新書叫做
萬萬黴想到裡面有提到
第一個D就是Drain
就是引流
再來是Detox
開始排毒了
第三個叫做Desensitize
就是去敏
最後一個是就是Drive
就是你要駕馭自己的人生
其實這本書我已經拜讀完了
寫得非常精彩
我覺得不管是一般民眾
或者是專業人士
對黴菌想要了解
非常推薦大家一定要去看
那在裡面我覺得一般民眾啊
可能可以應用的是一些精油的部分
可以先大概講一下說
精油對黴菌的幫助是在哪裡嗎
因為最早那時候
去上那些有關黴菌毒素的課的時候
他們都會提到一些精油
或者是我後來在查paper的時候啊
也發現
欸很多治療黴菌毒素的東西
怎麼都是精油才有
不管是飲食中或保健品都找不到
比如說玫瑰草
它對玉米赤黴烯酮的排毒率
可以達到99%
然後另外就是
譬如說野馬鬱蘭（又稱牛至）
然後還有桉油醇迷迭香
或者是羅馬洋甘菊
加上這個真正薰衣草
這兩個加起來其實對念珠菌
它的濃度只要小於1%
就對於念珠菌有這個抑制的效果
所以精油其實對於黴菌
或者是黴菌毒素
都有很好的一個排毒的效果
哇太棒了
其實王醫師講的這些東西呢
書裡面有寫
裡面都已經有教大家一些方法了
然後其實王醫師也為了這件事情
做了一支精油對不對
對沒錯
這支精油叫做降黴十八香
它的話就是用了18種精油
症狀跟黴菌或黴菌毒素有關的話
我都非常的推薦
然後尤其是它對於剛剛講的第一個
Drain就是引流
我覺得是特別有幫助的
怎麼用可以引流啊
其實它很好推
所以就是擠個一點點在手上
是
然後稍微把它推開
睡覺的時候會有一個
很重要的一個淋巴系統
叫做膠淋巴
它是跟我們的這個免疫功能很有關係的
所以如果說我們能夠在睡眠的時候
幫助這個膠淋巴系統可以引流的話
你會睡得很好
再來幫助排毒
再來就是對剛剛講的認知功能
也都很有幫助
大部分的研究都是
針對失智症跟阿茲海默症
那很簡單
就是我們可以摸到脖子前面
都可以摸到脈搏嘛
那這個就是頸動脈
旁邊就是有這個頸靜脈
跟迷走神經
還有淋巴系統都是一起走的
所以只要很簡單的用手
慢慢的往心臟的方向
向心方向去做一個按摩
那不需要很大力
其實輕輕的就可以了
就可以讓它有一個排毒的效果
這是第一個很重要的點
那第二個很重要的點
就是在我們的這個地方
這裡叫做第一頸椎橫突
他在這個耳朵後面
有一個硬硬的叫乳突的地方
還有下顎骨之間
是一個凹點
凹點凹進去的地方
這裡的話因為有非常多的神經交錯
所以很多人按起來都是很痠的
它也是膠淋巴系統最容易卡住的位置
所以這裡按一按
其實是可以幫助睡眠
然後幫助這個膠淋巴系統的排毒
太棒了這樣就有一個
可以很實質的事情可以做了對不對
可以的可以的
我們一定可以把黴菌毒素排出去
我也很好奇就是
你的症狀那些後來改善的程度
我自己真的是大幅度的改善了
我的疲勞感跟過敏
真的就是因為治療黴菌毒素之後
大概九成九都好了
所以大家都
幾乎都可以達到這樣子的狀況嗎
幾乎都可以
然後我覺得治療黴菌毒素就是
讓我很有成就感啦
然後讓病人也覺得很開心
那我當然不是說你的疲勞跟
這個鼻子過敏
一定是因為黴菌毒素造成的
其實你只要找對了病因
治療效果都很好
今天聽下來
大家會發現黴菌跟你想像的不一樣
黴菌毒素對我們造成的傷害
也是非常多
不過呢聽完以後也覺得
有事情可以幫助我們改善健康的
所以現在就去你家裡找一找
看看家裡有沒有什麼
冷氣啊發霉的角落啊
壁癌啊地毯啊
任何可能發現黴菌的角落
歡迎你在下面留言跟我們分享
那也可以幫助到
可能跟你有一樣問題的觀眾喔
我們今天非常謝謝王醫師
然後也謝謝大家
如果喜歡我們的頻道的話
記得幫我們訂閱分享按讚
開啟小鈴鐺
那我們下集再見了掰掰